welcome to exploring computing
today's video is cloud computing
so there are multiple uses of the term
cloud computing and so you need to be a
little bit careful
and think about who you're talking to
and what they might mean when they're
talking about cloud computing
in its basic usage cloud computing or
the cloud is just referring to
anything that's up on the network so i
could be referring to a file server
a mail server or media server so if i
say something like when i take a photo
on my iphone
the photo is stored or uploaded to the
cloud that is completely accurate
it's going up on the internet somewhere
or
if i say i back up my critical documents
to the cloud by storing them on dropbox
that is also
entirely accurate however when i'm
talking about cloud computing
in a business situation particularly if
i'm talking about a tech company
and we're talking about using the cloud
this will often mean we're replacing
computers that were previously
physically present
at the company site with remote
computers that are either partly or
completely managed by someone else
and so under the traditional model we
manage and store
our own computers on our own premises
we're responsible for security
we're responsible providing power to
them we're responsible for controlling
the network
both within those computers uh
interconnecting those computers and
connecting us to the wider internet
and again under the traditional model if
we need more computers
we order those computers um it takes
them a while to arrive
they arrive they're delivered to our
site we need to set them up
we need to get them on the network we
need to make sure everything's working
properly
and under the traditional model again if
there are updates or security patches
issued for
software or the operating system that
our computers are using
we need to make sure that this is taken
care of we are responsible for all the
security
now uh in order to understand how the
traditional model
differs from cloud computing i'm going
to take a look at
two uh very closely related
early models of how cloud computing
might work and so
you can kind of view this as a vision of
the future of where things are headed
and most but not all of the things that
we're going to see in these models are
available now um so two dif
two again closely related models of
cloud computing
that that people came up with were
utility computing
and grid computing and so the term
utility computing comes from the concept
of a public utility such as water or
electricity
and grid computing the name grid comes
from the concept of the electric grid
if you think about how the water system
works or how the electric good grid
works i have certain interactions within
certain expectations on what i
do need to do when i'm when i'm working
with that utility and what i don't need
to do with that utility
so let's take a look at the electric as
our example
um so suppose it's winter and it's
starting to get cold
and you know when it starts getting cold
can vary from one year to another but
i have a bunch of electric heaters
sitting around my house and
when it starts getting cold i plug in my
electric heaters into the wall and
i crank them up um i don't notify the
electric company when i need more
electricity the electric company just
has a whole bunch of electricity
hopefully it doesn't run out which as
we've seen does occasionally happen but
generally speaking there's a lot of
electricity there i just plug my
devices into the wall i plug my heaters
into the wall and i start using them i
don't call up the electric company ahead
of time and i say
hey you know um it's starting to get
cold
i think starting next thursday i'm gonna
need some more electricity
can you add a bit of extra electricity
to my bill
and then if if i use it great and if i
don't well i guess i'm gonna have to pay
for it because i told you to increase my
electric
uh output you know that doesn't happen
right you just
take your heater you plug it into the
wall and it goes
and i definitely don't have to go to the
store
to increase my electric capacity i don't
go to the store
i don't think hey it's winter i hear
it's going to be really cold winter this
year
i need to buy a whole bunch of
generators i'm going to go to the store
get those generators or maybe i'll tell
amazon send me some generators over get
them set up
you know get my whole uh little house
grid set up you know i don't do any of
that
this is all taken care of for me i just
plug things into the wall
and stuff is just there for me and when
it starts heating up again when it's
spraying i don't need my uh
heaters anymore i don't call the
electric company say hey
i i don't think i need the heaters
anymore so please reduce my bill
um i don't need those anymore and then
uh
it's summer same thing you know so my
usage goes up and down
depending upon the season um and i don't
notify the electric company i don't need
to make any special moves
the electricity is just there at the
wall when i need it
and so that's the whole idea behind
utility computing and grid computing the
idea is
just like the electricity is there when
i need it just like the water is there
when i
open up the tap it's just a widely
available
good that's managed by this external
utility company
the idea behind grid computing or
utility computing is the exact same
thing except for
for computing power there's computing
power it's available on demand
i can scale up or scale down as i need
if we happen to have uh
you know we're running a bunch of
simulations in february
uh we need more computing power we don't
need to notify anybody we need more
computing power we just you know plug
into the wall and that computing power
is there for us
um i don't need to determine my needs in
advance and i can scale up and scale
down as needed
we're done running those simulations
it's february let's say mid-march we're
done running those simulations
we don't need so much computing power
anymore we don't tell anybody we just
stop using it
and we stopped paying for it the same
way when i stopped running my space
heaters
i stopped paying for the electricity so
you know this is the idea behind
uh utility or grid computing this is
what we're really shooting for
so let's kind of compare these two
models and
you know one of the big benefits of
having utility or
grid model is that there's just a huge
tremendous amount of flexibility and
agility
that it gives businesses because under
the traditional model
i need to determine my needs in advance
i need to
contract with a supplier who's going to
supply me with actual computing devices
i need to wait for them to get delivered
i need to install them
you know this all takes advanced
forecasting out of the utility
or grid model i don't worry about
what we need in advance it's just there
and available for me
and on the traditional model if we
overestimate well we've got a whole
bunch of servers that we paid for
we spent all this time installing and
getting set up and we don't need them
because
we didn't have as much demand for our
product as we wanted under the utility
or grid model
if we don't have the demand we thought
we might have that's kind of unfortunate
but at least we aren't stuck with these
extra servers sitting around
we only get what we're uh what we need
and we only pay for what is actually
used if we
underestimate under the traditional
model
we're gonna have to turn away our
customers we're gonna say all right
um that's great you wanna use our
service
we're gonna order some more servers uh
we might have more capacity in a couple
days
you'll have to wait till then under the
utility or grid model
that power is just available for us if
we need more power
great more power is available
[Music]
all right another big advantage of the
grid or utility model is the computers
aren't actually located at my
company so on the traditional model if i
have
uh something that you know it's
important that we provide
proper security for it i'm responsible
providing security
under the utility grid model the cloud
computing company provides the security
under the traditional model if i'm
concerned
that i need good uptime on this i need
to have
backup electric power so that if the
power goes out
my generators get turned on under the
utility grid model that's the
responsibility of the cloud computing
company
um under the traditional model if i'm
concerned about
uh you know having multiple geographic
locations because
heaven forbid if the power goes out in
california and somebody's tries to
access it in our computer in california
well we've got kind of a problem there
or if the network in california is
having a problem we
kind of have a problem so you know we
might want to have
our computer devices in multiple
geographic locations and under the
traditional model
i'm going to have to go rent those
buildings in multiple geographic
locations i'm going to have to have
personnel
at those different locations to keep
track and support these computers
out of the utility grid model the cloud
computing companies has lots of
different locations and
um you know that's great and not only
does it support
uh this idea that if if one of the
centers
has problems if there's a power outage
somewhere or network out of somewhere
i've got multiple locations so like my
customers can continue to access it
it also provides lower latency because
you know if i have
uh stuff at the amazon services
in washington state um and i also have
them out in virginia if somebody's
trying to access my stuff from the east
coast well we can route them to
the virginia server and they'll have
much less latency
and they'll get the data back back much
faster because they're they're closer
located and that goes even further
when we're talking about situations
where we have international customers
i have a server in australia uh and
somebody's actually from australia
that's going to get them much faster
access okay so as i suggested earlier
when we started this
modern cloud computing doesn't yet have
all the
things that we were hoping for with
utility or grid computing but we're
getting pretty close
we're going to take a look at four
different cloud computing models
infrastructure as a service sometimes
referred to as is
platform does stores refer to as pass
serverless and then software as a
service referred to as sas
under infrastructure as a service the
provider is going to
provide the basic computer
infrastructure
and i is the customer i'm going to
organize the infrastructure as needed so
this is an example here amazon web
services has virtual private cloud and
by the way
i should mention amazon web services by
itself is
a huge company with a very wide range of
product options so if somebody tells you
they're using amazon web services aws
that doesn't really tell you what
they're doing
you need to know which specific service
they're using on aws
so the virtual private cloud service vpc
the way this would work is our company
would contract for a given number of
amazon ec2 instances
these are elastic cloud instances
and so these are basically virtual
machines
our it professionals would set up these
ec2 instances with whatever operating
systems we wanted on them
and we would set up our network
structure between these ec2 instances we
could set up some of the ec2 instances
is sort of
internal to our own virtual private
cloud where
outsiders couldn't have direct access to
them and then we could set some of the
ec2 instances
as externally visible as sort of public
things that different people could
access and so so what we're seeing here
is we have a bunch of computers they are
up on the cloud but
we need to do the setup ourselves
and so what we get out of is is
it's similar to having your own
computers except for it's much easier to
add and remove instances
as needed so you know as i mentioned
earlier if we're following the
traditional model if we need more
computers we need to order those
computers those computers need to be
physically delivered
to our premises we need to set them up
and we need to get everything installed
with infrastructure as a service if we
need more instances we just
go to our little webpage on amazon aws
and i crank up the number of instances
we need and
bang i instantly have a whole bunch more
instances
now um not only
is it better because i can scale up and
scale down as needed with just a click
of a button but again as we talked about
earlier
uh amazon is likely gonna have better
security than
we are gonna have on our own unless you
know i mean if i'm a really large
company
or the government i suppose i could get
really good security but you know if
you're a small
sized company or a mid-sized company
amazon's going to have better security
it's going to have probably better
network access it's going to have
better electric system reliability and
they have centers all around the world
so
not only do we scale up and down very
easily but uh
a lot of the sort of nitty-gritty of
making sure that everything's up we have
good uptime
we have a secure system uh that's all
completely taken care of so that's great
that's a big load off of us but at the
same time
with is i still need a extensive highly
trained
i.t staff we are maintaining and
updating our own servers
as if they were on the local premises
even though they're actually on the
cloud so we're handling all the
maintenance for handling all the updates
we're doing all the setup we're doing
all the normal it stuff
the big difference is they are not on
the physical premise they are up on the
cloud and again we can
we can add and remove them as needed
very very easily
okay so that's um that's not looking so
much like the computing grid
uh that's that's not looking so much
like the utility or grid computing that
i promised
there are some some some benefits such
as
easily increasing or decreasing
instances but you can see that
uh i am managing a lot i have an it
staff
that is handling a lot of the stuff and
so there's some
pretty clear benefits of using is in
terms of the advantage over
having physically on premise but in
addition
um you know you may be like well why
would you want to have your own i.t
staff doing it well i can set up these
computers in any way i want so
now i'm getting some of the key benefits
of having stuff up on the cloud
being able to scale up and down about
not needing to forecast that much in
advance
about not needing to provide security
etc etc
but i still have the complete
flexibility as if these were my own
computers
all right platform as a service so a
platform as a service the computing
platform is provided for me my
company is only responsible for the
application software running on that
platform
so heroku and amazon elastic beanstalk
are examples of pass
and so here's another aws service amazon
elastic beans
um so you know there's there's going to
be
differences between the different past
models but let's say we're using heroku
so i'm going to go ahead and write my
application in one of the languages that
heroku supports
so maybe i use javascript node.js or
maybe i use ruby or php
you know they have a bunch of different
languages that they support
i store my code using git which is a
version control system
and when i'm ready i tell git to send my
code to heroku
and my code is now live on the internet
so
you know with heroku i'm not setting up
my own network
i'm mostly not configuring my own
computers
which is what we saw on is
i'm don't have access to a lot of the
aspects of the operating system
so you know i'm i'm not setting up the
interconnections between a bunch of
ec2 instances so a lot of that stuff is
taken care of
i'm able to focus much more on just what
my application is doing
this gives me less flexibility but it
makes things a lot lot easier for me to
deal with
um i can choose to add some extra
instances so you know if i
if i decide i need more power i can go
ahead and do that and there are some
options that i can configure so it's not
like there's no configuration at all
i can decide whether i want databases uh
there's a bunch of other add-on packages
i can pay extra money for but
for the most part like this is super
simple compared to infrastructure as a
service where i install the operating
system on these virtual
machines i get all my virtual instances
uh in the virtual private cloud i get
them all configured like
so there's much less need for it staff
with platform as a service
mostly i just put my application onto
the instance and heroku takes care of
the rest
okay our next model is serverless and
this is getting much
more towards what uh utility and grid
computing
had intended basically i don't have any
virtual computing instances
instead i just have hey here's a
function i want to run
and so the best example of this would be
amazon lambda this is another aws
service so again
lots of amazon web services types of
services so
you know again if somebody says we're
using aws
you need to know exactly which the many
many services of aws are using
so in amazon lambda i write a function
that i want to call remotely
i upload the function code amazon and
then i call that function remotely as
needed
and i just pay for however many
computing resources get used by
somebody calling that function over the
month and they just send me the bill at
the end of the month so
um very much like
the original grid computing model uh you
know i i don't
configure anything i don't need to
determine how many instances i want
um i certainly don't figure out you know
what operating systems i want to deal
with operating system patches i'm just
like
hey here's a bunch of code whenever i
call this code just go ahead and run it
for me so that's actually pretty cool
all right our last model is software as
a service
this one's a little bit different it
doesn't really fit in with the other
models because
in the previous models you certainly
won't have an end
customer you know but like if i'm joe
customer i am not going to sign up for
infrastructure as a service i'm not
going to sign up for platform as a
service
and i'm not going to sign up for
serverless
but i certainly might sign up for
software as a service and in fact
most of us use software as a service at
some point or another
so software as a service means a company
is providing software to other people as
a service
typically that software will be mostly
run on the provider's computers although
as we saw in our discussion of
client-side versus server-side
processing
in most of these cases there will be a
client-side component so
when we go and this is this is typically
going to be
this will often be done in conjunction
with the web and we
when we go visit the website it's going
to go ahead and send us a client-side
program so
technically some of the software as a
service will be running on the
client-side
computer but uh this is generally
considered as
this is being handled by the uh the
company providing the software's the
services is being run by their computers
so example of software as a service is
google docs so
google is providing software uh
up on the web and people are visiting
the google website and taking advantage
of that
of google docs so
advantages of software as a service for
customers um the it
department does not have to deal with
anything so if you've got a whole bunch
of people in your company
many of who you know are not tech people
who may not be exercising the best
uh security installing random games on
their computers
um you know that's kind of a concern and
so you need a tech department that's
keep
keeping track of everything trying to
make sure that their
version of microsoft word or whatever
does not get infected or anything well
with software as a service all the stuff
is
on on the uh the provider's
website on the provider's servers and
your it company doesn't have to deal
with it if there's
a update if google docs gets updated for
example
and i go visit the google docs website i
am using the latest version of the
software
um if they've changed the client side
code that's going to get automatically
updated when i go visit that website
it's going to get sent from the server
to my web browser and i will always be
running the latest version of the code
another advantage is this software is
usually designed for the network in mind
because it's always designed to be
always running on the network and so
these pieces of software
will often have more collaborative
features built in than traditional
software so
um you can see this with google docs
which has lots of
nice features that uh that different
people on the team can sort of work
together
uh microsoft is trying to add these
features in but
you know traditionally microsoft word or
excel was not designed to have multiple
people accessing it simultaneously
and whereas google docs has always had
in mind that this is running on the
internet and so
that's the sort of design choices they
can make while the initially designing
the software
um as far as somebody that's providing
this service there's a number of big
benefits as well
and so one of the nice things about
software as a service is it often
requires a subscription which means you
have a steady stream of income which is
always nice
in addition if you're running something
that has software as a service you're
much less concerned with copy protection
because
people don't run it on their own they
run it by visiting your server and so
you can keep track of
people's uh logins and if if they want
to log into the server you can check are
they paying customer or not whereas
with traditional software somebody can
make a duplicate copy
install on a different computer um it's
on a whole bunch of
people's computers even though they
haven't paid for it so um software as a
service has
advantages both as a customer where
uh you know your it department doesn't
have to worry about
keeping everything upgraded and up to
date and installed on everybody's
computer and then it has benefits
to the provider as well
okay so we've been talking about cloud
computing
um there's actually another set of
models of computing associated with
running on the network but
separate from the cloud and so there's a
number of different terms
these are all somewhat interrelated so
edge computing
fog computing or mesh computing and so
the destroying
edge fog and mesh computing versus cloud
computing is typically we think of the
cloud as
somewhere out far away on the internet
but for some types of applications in
some application architectures
we may want to distinguish between
things that are far away on the internet
meaning cloud computing versus things
that are nearby
but not on our device so somewhere
nearby on a nearby network or on our
current network
versus stuff that is physically on our
own device
and so here's the nuances between
edge fog and mesh computing edge
computing is referring to the edge
between the internet and our own device
so it's like again nearby fog computing
is similar
the main term fog computing was meant as
a contrast to cloud computing
where again cloud is considered far away
on the internet
and then mesh computing focuses on
having more decentralized networks that
may
possibly form in an ad hoc manner and
provides for more robust networks and
we'll talk about this in a couple
minutes why you
why you might want this okay so what's
the benefits of
edge fog or mesh computing versus cloud
computing
well consider working in a remote
environment
so to provide an example i found those
examples on ge digital i thought this
was a great example
uh you've got an offshore platform so
you've got a you know you're you're
drilling for
oil out in the middle of the gulf um yes
maybe you do have a connection to the
internet but you have limited connection
to the internet possibly slower but also
limited bandwidth and so
and so edge or fog computing sort of
focuses on this idea that
hey you know we can handle some things
internally on our network here
uh on our offshore platform
and then we can also talk to the cloud
depending upon what we're doing so it's
it does we want to distinguish between
stuff that we're handling
locally within our internet here on the
offshore platform versus what's
happening further out and then uh you
know
hopefully soon we will have similar
issues in space where
you know maybe you've got a bunch of
people on the moon um they can still
communicate with earth but
you know they have limited bandwidth and
they certainly have a huge latency
when trying to communicate with the
earth and then of course mars would have
even bigger issues so
the idea here is the closer we are to
the device
um you know we've got stuff going on in
the local
closer network uh either the local
network or
you know we might have our own little
intra network um
you can imagine on mars we've got our
own little intra network it's we've got
a bunch of networks a network of
networks
but then uh we're we are largely
separated from the internet on earth
okay so uh we're gonna have reduced
bandwidth requirements to the overall
internet so we've got some local stuff
uh
our our smaller network it does
communicate with the larger internet
but we've got reduced bandwidth
requirements we're trying to keep the
amount of bandwidth we need to send to
the larger internet
to a minimum we've got reduced latency
again
uh you know depending upon where we're
located and what our communications
to the larger internet looks like there
could be a fairly big delay between
when we send information off to the
larger internet and when we get
results back and so this is actually one
of the reasons
why some people are looking at this for
cell phone usage
um the european telecommunication
standard is working on edge computing
and the idea here is that they want to
reduce the amount of traffic that goes
over the cell phone towers and so if
they can handle some of the processing
at the cell
phone tower itself they won't have to
send the data any further so
that's another potential use of edge or
fog or mesh computing
and some of these types of computing
focus on
trying to provide for more robust models
and so
uh this is a particular focus on mesh
computing
what you want is you want a distributed
computer model that does not have a
single point of failure so remember a
while back
uh probably about three four weeks ago
when we were talking about how the
network worked
i mentioned that one of the issues with
the star network is you've got a central
failure point so
our example of a star network that we
all use
is the wi-fi network if the wi-fi router
goes down
we're all host and so the idea behind a
mesh network is
you want to have a more robust model
where
if one of the nodes goes down you can
keep on working
so self-healing network if some of the
nodes are lost
um and as you might imagine these type
of designs are particularly important
for military applications so
you know if you've got that command
vehicle and it is the central point of
failure and something happens to it
uh you don't want the whole network to
go down you still want people
to be able to communicate with each
other and still um maintain network
connectivity and so
for some people working in this area
this is a key key issue that they're
trying to look into
and trying to create robust mesh
computing
one thing i do want to mention is that
this does not replace cloud computing
necessarily and that
it can often be done in conjunction with
traditional cloud computing so
handle some requests at the edge and
then
pass additional requests onto the cloud
and this also often
involves devices other than traditional
computers and
this brings us to the internet of things
which is actually what our next video is
going to be talking about
so i will talk to you about the internet
of things shortly
you